when you shift the paradigm of whatever
it is you choose to do to service and
you bring significance to that success
will I promise you follow you how do you
serve other people and make money doing
at the same time and so for me to break
that down there's two things the more I
serve people the more I made a
difference the more I contributed the
more I was rewarded financially
rise and shine it's in spresso time
what's up believe nation at 7:00 my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent adds something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's start your day off
right together grab your coffee and sip
on today's message find a way to serve
over to you Oprah Winfrey you must find
a way to serve Martin Luther King
said that not everybody can be famous
but everybody can be great because
greatness is determined by service now
we live in a world where everybody wants
to be famous and where we admire people
for just being famous we think being
known brings us value the truth is all
of that will fade in time in three years
you won't be able to name the Housewives
a banana the real truth is that service
and significance service and the
significance that you bring to your
service is that which is lasting so to
be able to whatever your occupation or
job or talent or gift is our honorees
today getting Doctorate degrees -
apparently opposite fields HIV and AIDS
and the spoken word but what they have
in common is service using the spoken
word in service to community in the
world using your knowledge and
information about HIV and AIDS and
medicine in service to the world and if
you look at all the most successful
people in the world whether they know it
or not
they have that paradigm of service
everybody's talking about Mark
Zuckerberg and IPO service jay-z rapid
service through the word to people
through song for many years I was really
just happy to be on TV and people would
stop and say oh you on TV yeah I'm on TV
I like being on TV
it's a nice job and it was about the
time that I received my honorary
Doctorate from Spelman around 1993 so I
don't know if that had something to do
with it I thought of myself as dr.
Winfrey that I went back and I took the
long look at what it was I was doing on
on TV and made a decision that I was no
longer going to just be on TV but I was
going to use TV as a platform as a force
for good and not be used by TV and I
will tell you my decision to make that
significant change in the way I operated
on television using television as a
service changed my career exponentially
service through medicine service through
art using whatever it is you produce
your product as a way of giving back to
the world when you shift the paradigm of
whatever it is you choose to do to
service and you bring significance to
that success will I promise you follow
you service and significance equals
success service is at the core of every
successful business especially if you
want to have longevity you want to be
around for a long period of time the
number one rule about making money is
you have to provide value and so by
starting with the customer in mind first
by thinking about how can you be of
service to them how can you help them
get to where they need to go by making
that your default before you worry about
the business model that's when you start
to win now a lot of people start
thinking then great okay I want to serve
others I think I think it's just a
natural
thing I think people want to serve other
people I think you feel good about
yourself when you serve somebody else
when you can help them in some way I
think the challenge a lot of people have
is I want to serve somebody else I want
to serve others I want to have an impact
I don't know how to make money doing it
how do you serve other people and make
money doing at the same time and so for
me to break that down there's two things
this one the mindset the mindset of you
can charge for this you should charge
for this you should probably raise your
prices in what you're doing right now
you are probably under valuing yourself
if it's free you're definitely under
valuing yourself if you are charging for
it you still are probably under valuing
yourself you should still try raising
your prices 30 percent and see what
happens
and then to these specific actions how
do you monetize how do you take that
service mindset and then be able to make
money what are the specific steps that
you need to take this can be different
for different industries but what I
recommend is a specific next step is to
model success is to find the person who
you think is doing a good job of it find
the person who is serving other people
and doing it in a way that you think is
respectful and the right way to do it
the way that you wish you could do it in
your industry with your customers and
then get as close to them as possible
that might mean trying to get a job with
them if you're gonna have a job anyway
it might as well be a job where you are
learning where you are in an industry
that you want to be a part of as opposed
to some unrelated industry that is just
financing your dream right get a job in
that business to try to get as close to
the person as possible through the
content they're putting out do they have
a youtube channel
are they on Instagram are they on
Twitter do they have books do they have
podcast just try to consume be around
them if you start your day every day
with the person that inspires you who's
leading the life through service and
making money doing it then you will pick
up their mindset their habit their
strategies a way of thinking start your
day with it every day
and then 3 just try to actually get a
little bit of face time with them if you
are not going to go and work for them
but you want something in between
working for them and just listening to
their content or watching our content
then do they have a seminar you know a
lot of people came out to the workshop
that I had in May
I've got another one in September these
are people who want to be thought
leaders you get me for three days to
help you be a thought leader and make
money doing it does the person you love
go live on Instagram or live on
periscope or live on YouTube can you go
and ask some questions do they have an
event coming up somewhere close to where
you live can you go and ask questions at
that event and for all of these things
this is what's real important if you get
your chance if you get your moment
whether it's on an Instagram live or at
a seminar at an event there's always a
Q&A section be the first put your hand
up
no have an intention going in I want an
answer to this question you've consumed
all of their content you know what
they're about you're trying to figure
out this little piece be the first to
put your hand up because the first
person puts their hand up they get their
question answered but if you don't want
to be first if you're afraid then guess
what somebody else goes first and then
the huge lineup forms and then time runs
out off and other people who really
wanted to ask a question don't let that
be you if there's a question you want to
answer it be the first there and ask it
early so if you're coming from the place
of I don't care about certain people I
just want to make money
you've lost our writer your mindset is
broken you will lose you might make a
little bit of short-term money by
ripping people off but long term you
have lost and you won't feel good about
yourself you will not feel good about
yourself you won't have the fulfillment
cuz you're ripping people off you're not
giving them great service but if you
coming from the place that you believe
in service and you don't know how to
monetize it and you want to figure out
how can I do both how can I embrace that
and I want to be a fantastic value and
service people to the best of my
capabilities and I want to become filthy
rich doing it so I can have a bigger
impact and build a team and go off and
do more than the fastest shortcut that I
know is to model the success and get us
close to the people who are doing what
you want to do as possible I've got a
really special bonus clip for you but
before that question today I want to
know who is that person for you who was
the person who was serving others and
making money doing it that you want to
get as close to as possible that you
want to model their success their
mindset from leaving the comments below
I'm curious to find out thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one where it is much
love I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot
Oven spresso and enjoy the bonus clip
[Music]
everything in your life happens for you
not to you I'm just a huge believer in
that and so my baseball dream ended I
had an injury probably gave me a
premature and to occur that would have
ended anyways in hindsight because I
played with enough great players that I
kind of know there was a gap in just
god-given ability level not work ethic
but yeah I think to be the greatest
there has to be some proclivity for it
and work ethic right and so I kind of
maxed out my limited abilities and so
when I got released I ended up moving
back home with my parents I couldn't
find a job I was depressed I spent about
a year at my parents house just broke in
every way financially spiritually
mentally physically I remember my dad
came home my dad had just got sober and
my dad said to me hey I met this guy at
a meeting I got you a job you get your
ass down there tomorrow morning at 6:00
a.m. getting out of this house getting a
job and I'm like okay I have a college
degree
you know I'm being picky for a year
watching Maury Povich reruns everyday on
TV and Jerry Springer I go down there at
6:00 a.m. I walk in I said hey my name
is Eddie might let him here for the job
they're like what job I remember this
vividly right and I'm like I don't know
they just told me you'd know and they go
well we have no idea who you are and we
don't know what the job is they said do
you know who's hiring you I said I don't
remember and they go well then you need
to come back and I go to the door and I
go wait a minute
his name's Tim they're like there's a
lot of Tim's and I go well I know he
must be an alcoholic because he was at a
meeting with my dad laughter they go
drunk Tim we know Tim right and where I
was was a place called McKinley Home for
Boys it was a group home a campus of
group homes all my boys were Ward's of
the court they were removed from their
family either because their parents were
incarcerated killed or were molesting
them and I ended up in cottage eight
cottage eight I had 12 boys they were 7
to 10 years old and I walk through that
door that morning not even knowing what
the job was and it transformed my life I
mean in an instant brother I just saw
these eyes these little boys and they
just wanted someone to love him and
believe in him and care about him and
I'd have this big belief that people
that go through any dysfunction and
their family or abuse as a kid I think
our eyes are different we just have
these different eyes man and so I could
connect with these guys mine wasn't as
severe as theirs but I knew what it was
like
have that kind of anxiety and that kind
of stress and that kind of pressure put
on you as a little boy and I became like
their father I was there with him on
Christmas and Halloween and their
birthdays and I lived with them and it
changed my world because in that instant
I went from being this athlete who was
ego recognition significance gonna get
rich it's all about me always when
you're a good athlete you knew this
growing up was always accolades all of a
sudden in that instant it became about
serving people making a difference
nothing like oh this is what makes me
happy oh I was actually born to serve
and help people crazy no one that never
happened playing baseball and while I
work there two years into it the
financial business that I'm in came
along and I started in a part-time and
I'm the I was the rare young businessman
who approached the business world from a
place of service and giving and not
making money and ironically the more I
serve people the more I made a
difference the more I contributed the
more I was rewarded financially I didn't
do it for that reason but that's what
happened so that's how I got into the
business was actually and again
everything that my dad wasn't an
alcoholic he's not at that meeting I
don't get that job and if he wasn't if
it wasn't how guy wouldn't it connected
with those boys so all of that in
hindsight happened for me right and and
had I met the financial business before
that I'd have flown out of it I'd have
been about ego making money and when
that didn't happen out of left and so it
all happened in the right sequence Wow
someone asked me what's the number one
lesson I would like to give to myself if
I can go back 20 years in time right and
that lesson would be the lesson that I
already share with my kids right now see
I'm raising kids right now who are gonna
be entrepreneurs they're gonna be change
makers they're gonna be a useful part of
society and and I'm guessing that if
you're following me if you watch my
stuff you can subscribe to my channel if
you if you want anything to do with me
then you care about impact you care
about meaning you want to build an
empire that leaves a legacy behind
happen listen up young entrepreneurs for
that to happen you're going to have to
wake up every morning and pick between
one of two shirts now the shirt that I
used to pick to wear every morning said
what can you do for me see I was a
pretty selfish guy I was the type of guy
that always looked to you and you and
you and try to figure out what can you
do for me I'm gonna get something for
you how can I find a loophole where's
the value in it for me these days I wake
up on anonymous shirt that says how can
I help you see the more people you can
help the more people you can serve the
more you'll get what you want
Zig Ziglar said his best years ago when
he said the more you can help others get
what they want then you'll get what you
want right and so every morning when you
wake up you have one of two shirts to
wear you can either be selfish and wear
the shirt that says what can you do for
me
or you could be a giver a servant leader
that says how can I serve you and the
more people that you serve the better
your life will be I promise you and
course the bigger the Empire you'll
plate building and the more impact
you'll make best of all you'll have
peace of mind knowing that you're
helping out humanity which at the end of
the day we're all here on this planet to
have some sense of meaning right so wear
that shirt how can I help you
now terrific world domination honey
Empire right I'm grateful I understand
why I'm here I think because I am so
open I wanted to think and see it's a
bloody brief life all of you have the
potential for enormous success if you
want to know what gary vee DJ khalid
oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video